THAT IS MOSTT.
LOOK AROUND FOR LINDGREN,
LINDGREN TRYING TO SIDE AND THE
PASS ACROSS GOT TIPPED AWAY.
IN THE FRONT OF 12 AND HOW QUIC,
A TWO-ON-ONE IN TIGHT, AND
FOR DUBOIS, AND IGOR SHESTERKIN
WITH ANOTHER BIG PAD STOP THAT
PSYCHE OF THE ON DE-FEBRUARYS
THIS IS TO HAVE THE BACK BOARDS.
PIONK,AST FOUR
GAMES FOR SVECHNIKOV.
HE HAS HIMSELF AS A
REAL QUA
GO AND CONSERVE ENERGY ON THE
SPEEDY TEAM.
YOUR FORE-CHECK FROM BEING
MAN, KILLING 17 OF THE LAST 18
IN THEUPLE OF CHANCES HERE, FIR
IT'S ZIBANEJAD, A LITTLE
LOWRY, SAVE MAD CLEARS IT INTO
WINNIPEG JETS BENCH
THREE OF HIS LAST SIX POINTS
SHORTHANDED
>> Dennis: AT TIMES T THE OPENI.
PANARIN, TRYING TO
A LOT OF THEM ARE CARBON BY CON.
MORRISSEY, ON FOR SCHEIFELE.
>> Kevin: TWO SHOTS, TWOWO PERI
ONE.
SCHEIFELE, WALKS IT TO THEMORRI.
WATCHEOTS SO FAR IN
THIS GAME FOR THE
SECOND PERIOD IN THE FACE-OFF
DEPARTMENT
STROME TRYING TO CORRAL IT,
CAN'T.
PICKED UP BY DILLON, I'LLDRIVE
AND HELLEBUYCK, GOES FOR A POKE
CHECK, CAUGHT BETWEEN TWO R OF
IS RECOVERED.
BANK PASS,